[Music]
foreign
Judge Andrew Napolitano here for judging
Freedom today is Thursday September 29th
2022 it's about 5 15 in the afternoon
here on the east coast of the United
States
2 15 in the afternoon on California
where our guest is and regular
judging freedom of viewers know who Our
Guest is you can see him Dr Joel Wallach
with whom judging Freedom has partnered
in Dr wallach's program judging Health
you go to judginghealth.com you'll get
direct access to 5 000 supplements to
keep you stronger to keep you healthy
and to ward off diseases Dr Wallach
today is going to talk to us about
osteoporosis of the skull okay I'm
pretty well educated Dr Wallach but what
the heck is osteoporosis of the skull
and welcome here my dear friend well
thank you so much it's an honor always
your honor to be with you and Gary you
guys are doing a great job and I'm just
honored to be part of the team thank you
well osteoporosis of the skull is the
same as osteoporosis of the vertebrae
osteoporosis of the pelvis osteoporosis
your leg bones your arm bones your
fingers your toes
osteoporosis of the skull of course
that's above the neck doctors don't know
anything about that they only want to do
osteoporosis below the skull because
they can do near replacement they can't
do a skull replacement
and so they just say what is
osteoporosis freestanding what does the
word mean and what does it connote okay
what it cannotes is you're losing all
the minerals out of your skull this
happens it starts out in kids when
they're teenagers they go to
orthodontists their teeth are floating
around they get receding gums they get
TMJ and which is a temporal mandibular
joint which is your jaw joint in your
skull
all the all the bone has gone away and
the the
um uh internal uh structure of the bone
when the minerals go away the internal
structure is kind of like connective
tissue it's kind of like cartilage and
it gets bigger and bigger and bigger
trying to make up the difference
well there's 12 pairs of cranial nerves
to either come out on either side and
then there's a spinal cord comes out of
the back of the skull and we're going to
quickly go over the 37 different
diseases that you get when you get
osteoporosis cold that will send you to
37 different specialists
and you'll spend thousands of dollars
and thousands of dollars on this for
treating the symptoms but guess what
it's a simple nutritional deficiency
disease
okay all right so before you get into
what osteoporosis of the skull can cause
what is osteoporosis I mean if I had it
in my knee or or on my shin what would
my symptoms be okay you get clicking in
your knee when you you know when you
bend your knees it would click and pop
it would swell up you have pain in your
knee and be one of those things where
just a minute
okay all you kids stop making noise
got grandkids here apologize right okay
do they have any idea how important
their grandfather is
okay I'm throwing things at him so I
think that'll help okay all right so
anyway
but the same thing happens in your your
vertebrae same thing happens in your
arms your fingers you know you get
fingers that click and so forth
um does it happen in the joints or in
the bones is it a deterioration of the
bone or the heart
okay it's a deterioration of the bone
but the cartilage sits on the bone so
when the bone goes away the cartilage
starts popping and cracking because his
support is going away
okay okay
and it's one of those things where
um the the breadth of the diseases you
get 37 different diseases we get
osteoporosis of the skull you're going
to be spending your life running around
to it starts out when you're a teenagers
I said because you go to an orthodontist
they'll put braces on you because your
teeth are floating around you're getting
receding gums you're TMJ okay temporal
Mandela joint arthritis
and then the doctors want to put in
dental implants sure they'll pull all
your teeth and give you dentures and
that kind of stuff you already have
actually approach to the skull when
that's all happening that's not
happening because of age that's not
happening because you're not brushing
your teeth that's happening because you
have nutritional deficiencies of your
skull and because you're not getting the
nutrition to the skull the Bony support
for your teeth and your gums and muscles
and stuff and nerves and
you'll see his as we go through these
diseases it'll freak out okay
so you know one of my uh Brothers Who's
now a grown man and a father and a
grandfather when we were kids he had
braces because it was obvious that his
teeth weren't as straight as mine we ate
the same food the same nutrition
prepared by the same wonderful mom was
now approaching 97 years old
what were his crooked teeth which are
now perfectly straight
you know many thousands of dollars and
much discomfort later from the
orthodontist where his crooked teeth
caused by a nutritional deficiency
that's correct
well we ate the same food and I didn't
have the nutritional deficiency oh but
maybe he's eating more gluten than you
and was not absorbing as many minerals
as you were
if he was eating double the bread double
the spaghetti double the pancakes double
the waffles double the oatmeal
and your his intestines are being killed
by the gluten he could not absorb the
nutrition
so what is the solution to this when the
person's teeth are already crooked not
to go to an orthodontist no you can go
to an orthodontist to straighten them up
but you still have to give your body the
raw materials it needs to maintain the
repairs that have been made otherwise
otherwise within months it'll be back
down in the hole
all right what other diseases can come
from osteoporosis of the skull okay well
here we go let's turn out remember
there's 12 pairs of cranial nerves in
the spinal cord which are all formed in
the brain and come out of the back of
the skull
you have to remember your honor the 25
of the brain weight is cholesterol it's
the myelin is a white matter of the
brain
25 percent of your spinal cord is
cholesterol and if people get on
cholesterol uh reducing drugs like
statin drugs or they stop eating eggs
and stuff like that because the doctor
says cut out all the cholesterol in your
life because you know you're getting
plaque in your arteries well cholesterol
doesn't cause the plaque in your
arteries
it's oxidized oils like salad dressings
cooking oils those kinds of things are
what cause plaque in your arteries not
the cholesterol doctors got that one all
wrong
okay
and they cause a mess
which is not unusual for doctors okay so
here we go cranial nerve number one okay
the olfactory nerve when it gets
squeezed by the skull when you have
osteoporosis going you lose your sense
of smell because so you know I just I
can't smell cooking food anymore I just
can't smell that anymore
and so or they can't smell exhaust from
the car they can't smell flowers uh here
smell this beautiful flower I don't know
I don't get anything but I smell it okay
that's because the skull is squeezing
cranial nerve number one the olfactory
nerve
cranial nerve number two okay the optic
nerve when it gets squeezed
okay you get optic nerve atrophy o n a
um the skull is squeezing the optic
nerve the optic artery optic vein you
get glaucoma you get pressure in the eye
uh you get cataracts you get you get
retinous retinitis a Pigmentosa you get
Mac Regeneration all because of
osteoporosis of squeezing the optic
nerve the optic artery in the optic vein
and then you have to go get surgery and
you have to get cataracts or you know
you're going to get um lenses put in
your eyes and replace the cataract
surgery and all that kind of stuff okay
and then um cranial nerve number three
okay the oculomotor nerve okay
um you're gonna get ptosis p-t-o-s-i-s
or the pupil okay and what happens is
the pupil will not respond to light you
know when the doctor puts that light in
your eye it's supposed to construct well
he'll put that light in your eye and the
people won't constriction you're going
oh I can't I can't handle it because the
light is bothering you well that's
because you have ptosis you have the
skull squeezing the third cranial nerve
okay all right so I I think we get the
picture what what is the solution to
prevent or reverse the skull from
squeezing these nerves whether it's uh
optic cranial or olfactory
well well that's only a part of them
there's 12 of them
but what what what is the what is the
way to address this okay the solution to
address these 37 different diseases is
to eliminate all the bad foods no fried
foods get rid of all the inflammation
oxidation get rid of all the fried foods
get rid of all the
oils no salad dressings no cooking oils
none of that kind of stuff you got to
get rid of the processed meat to all the
chemicals in them things like bacon and
ham Bolognese salami hot dogs pepperoni
jerky all that kind of stuff's got to go
and then you also have to get rid of
gluten no wheat no bar to Ryan oats no
wheat nobody Ryan oats doctors love it
they say oh you should be eating more
oatmeal for breakfast that'll help you
with your bowel movements now we're just
going to kill the lining of your
intestines which should look like a shag
rug with all the Villi from absorption
we need gluten and eat oatmeal for
breakfast all those Ville I go away and
instead of looking like a shag rug your
intestines now look like a plastic tube
you've lost 90 of your absorptive
surface and even if you're taking
supplements you're not going to be able
to absorb enough to prevent these
diseases okay
uh one of our one of our regular viewers
was very fond of you just asked me to
ask you about AFib
okay atrial fibrillation
is not a heart disease as the heart will
do irregular things and beat weirdly and
the doctors say look we've got to
anesthetize you cut you open take your
heart out uh take a hot Branding Iron
it's called ablation we're going to
touch the heart all over and try to find
the place that's running a muffin while
your heart is doing funny things no
um when you have ablation okay you don't
want that okay what's happening is
the 10th cranial nerve okay the 10th
cranial nerve is squeezing the is being
squeezed by the skull let me run up to
the tenth cranial nerve here is being
squeezed by the skull
uh here we go okay the vagus nerve and
you get two main problems one is atrial
fibrillation of the heart which is not a
heart issue it's actually obviously
positive skull squeezing that tense
cream nerve but also you get
gastroparesis I mean this is extreme
death-defying pain in the stomach
because that vagus nerve goes all the
way down into the stomach tells the
stomach what to do and when the skull is
squeezing that vagus nerve you get afib
in the heart and you get gastroparesis
the stomach the doctors say look we're
going to put this tube down your throat
when we look around in there for the
ulcer you've got so much pain you got to
have an ulcer in there we'll take out
half your stomach and blah blah blah
blah and so that's what's going on there
it's actually osteoporosis of the skull
causing this
okay
so once you have the osteoporosis of the
skull and all the squeezing of the
nerves
and the most important
physical responses to the squeezing will
a proper diet
and prop the ingestion of a proper
amount and proportion of minerals stop
the squeezing reverse the squeezing
sure you get an A plus
the answer is yes
okay there is we've been doing this
successfully
for about 25 years we put it all into
the book in the city by the same title
it's all in your head
it tells the average person with a sixth
grade education if you can read sixth
grade reading you get the book it's all
in your head you get the CD okay it's on
your head
and the recipe for eliminating
osteoporosis of the skull is in the book
and it's in the CD okay
and it's one of those things where
um I don't know how many we sell but I
mean it's one of our biggest sellers is
it's all in your head because Grandma
needs it grandpa needs it aunt and uncle
need it mom and dad need it and even
kids are born without she approaches to
the skull I think it was called herbs
palsy and and sometimes you'll think
it's cerebral palsy because a kid is
born perilous from the neck down because
the skull of that baby is squeezing the
spinal cord
causing him to be paralyzed from the
neck down when they're born it's called
herbs policy it's caused by osteoporosis
of the skull because the mother
was even if she's going to breastfeed
the baby she's been eating
oatmeal for breakfast drinking beer made
from wheat okay having noodles and
spaghetti at dinner time having waffles
and pancakes at breakfast for their
oatmeal and not taking any vitamins
minerals I'm eating well my doctor said
I can get everything I need just by
eating well well those doctors should go
to jail and have to pay for all of your
medical bills
laughs
if uh
folks watching us now have the symptoms
that you've described and they go to
judginghealth.com website will they be
able to navigate through to the type of
minerals that they should be taking or
should they also get this book because
it will talk to them about the foods
they should eat and the foods they
should avoid yes I would get the book
because the whole book and the CD are
directed towards the answer to your
question
okay you cannot miss it the the entire
book is dealing with what you do to
resolve osteoporosis of the skull
and to eliminate all the diseases
because not only do you need the 90s
essential nutrients which is basic stuff
which you need the what we call the
secret sauces for each thing you need
the secret sauces for your eyes you need
the secret substances for your ears you
need the secret sauces for your bones
and your skull you need the secret
sauces for your nerves the nerve fibers
and so on and so it's a little more
complex than just treating osteoporosis
of your legs yeah I suppose your legs
very simple
but as he approaches this call is a
little more complicated so that's why we
came out with a specific book and CD
just for osteoporosis of the skull
but it is from one standpoint easy
because it's the nutritional efficiency
is easy to prevent it's easy to get rid
of I mean I'm going on 84. and I don't
have any of those osteoporosis of the
skull things
okay I've never been on a prescription
drug except for three days when I had an
infection I fell into a ditch in a
construction site up in Canada and got
pierced by rebar got an infection how
long ago was this
um I would say that was about 15 years
ago
okay one of these days when we're
together I'll show you a picture of my
legs they were going to amputate my legs
you know if I'm gonna you're I'm gonna
die with my legs on just give me
intravenous antibiotics I'm going to die
with my legs on I'm not gonna let you
cut my legs off
thank God you knew what you were talking
about yeah listen and they listened to
you so well one of your uh fans also the
same person that asked about afib says
order one healthy Bone and Joint pack
per 100 pounds of body weight sounds
like this person is already a fan of the
website okay well that's going in the
right direction okay but it won't hurt
also
to um to take the ultimate daily classic
tablets take three of those twice a day
because they're going to help support
healthy blood flow through the arteries
in the heart
and also support healthy blood pressure
okay while you're going through this
process because all that's screwed up
because of that tenth cranial nerve
telling the heart to do weird things
so you still have to do the secret
sauces to go along with the two healthy
um you're crawling the secret sauces
are really tablets
uh hacked densely with minerals
addressed to this particular ailment
which also can be gotten on the website
judging Health that's that's correct the
secret sauces are either tablets or
powder or capsules or liquids depending
on the nature of the of the
nutrient okay
and um
uh these secret sauces
we have 5 000 of them
okay we have five thousand to deal with
over 600 different diseases
and so we get
people from all over the world who go to
some of the greatest well-known doctors
uh we have
um a new uh CD I'll make sure it gets
sent to you okay it's called the Dr Joel
uh Wallach story
did I in fact you could probably just go
online and get it for free uh the Dr
Joel Wallach story
look it up it's it's a I think it's a
video the Dr Joel Wallach story it's
only 30 minutes long
and it'll it'll blow your mind okay
well it kind of lays out the basic stuff
that everybody has to do to stay good I
repair yourself if you have problems
because the good lord gave us the
equipment to repair herself
but it does require nutrients you know
you don't just put dirt from Texas in
your car because you believe there's
gonna be oil in it dirt from Texas it's
and so you know just eating well isn't
good enough you have to take all these
nutrients because nutritional minerals
do not occur in a uniform blanket around
the crust of the earth occur in veins
like gold and silver
um nutritional minerals do not occur in
a uniform blank around the coast of the
earth plants do not make minerals plants
really make vitamins and amino acids
plants only need three minerals we and
other vertebrates require
60.
got it Dr Wallach it is always a
pleasure we will pick another ailment
that the medical community here's my
little crescent who wants his his dinner
with all of the vitamins and minerals in
them
you we will pick another uh ailment
which the medical community has falsely
diagnosed and attempted to uh correct
and we'll discuss it next week always a
pleasure thank you for joining us well
God bless you and your team sir uh we
love you and appreciate and respect you
God bless you and all the great things
that you and your team do God bless you
sir right back at you thank you Judge
Napolitano for judging freedom
right
[Music]